hello there so split gate was released
in july on pc and consoles and i
intended to make a video about how much
i like split gate but so many people
played the beta it broke the game i mean
it smashed the servers to smithereens
right now the game remains in beta but
servers are much more robust that i
think it's worth covering and oh yeah
the whole thing is absolutely free to
play so let's break it down and see why
you should give it a go and be want it's
addictive
[Music]
[Applause]
splitgate is an arena shooter a
forgotten genre that was thrown aside
when battle royale took over the world
if you're a halo player i'm sure you'll
see the similarities here but i'll be
honest i've never played a halo game but
if this is what they are like count me
in everyone starts off with the same
weapons in each game regardless of game
mode to keep things fair and r g free
but other weapons are available on the
battlefield which you will keep until
you die or run out of bullets but the
thing that makes split gate a must play
game are those portals each player has
two portals to throw down which are
linked together making an instant
doorway anywhere you choose well it's
not actually anywhere to prevent the
game from being unplayable only the
glowing blue walls can be used to portal
to and from your portals and everyone
else's portals can be shot through but
you can only see through your own portal
you'll need to decide if jumping through
another player's portal is worth it or
not shooting through them before you go
through is a pretty good idea to check
nobody is waiting for you on the other
side or the alternative is to be waiting
when someone tries to sneak up on you
we also have nades which do zero damage
confusing right completely harmless and
that's because they ain't here for
eliminating people they are here to
close portals they are emp grenades
don't like the look of that enemy portal
nade it to stop it being used simple the
final aspects that make split gate split
gate are those thrusters on our back not
quite enough power to send us to the
moon and back but more than enough to
get a little verticality into our game
you'll be looking up and down an awful
lot in split gate boots on the ground is
not the only way to play here oh and i
should mention that momentum plays a big
part in split gate if you go into one
portal damn fast he'll come out the
other one just as quick so enjoy the
hang time
right stop a second i have to put this
in because someone you know will
inevitably do this in game if there's a
player you can't quite catch up but they
turn a corner just as you turn a corner
you should know it's likely that you're
chasing yourself and yes mythbusters
alert it's indeed possible to shoot
yourself in the back of the head do with
this information what you will but
committing to doku doesn't help your
teammates
although it's a little bit funny
split gate has a butt ton of game modes
here are a few of them which i quite
like let's skip the usual team death
match in domination mode you already
know those what about these ones
takedown takedown is a three on three
squad match in which you have to
eliminate the entire opposition team at
the same time sounds hard well each time
they die their respawn timer extends
ultimately staying alive for 20 seconds
against a crack team of operatives is
harder than you think
showdown showdown is similar to takedown
but no respawning at all a single life
you and your squad take on the other
until one team wins six times this game
mode is great for learning how to stay
alive and to navigate portals to keep
your distance of course it's a complete
nightmare with randoms but that's fun
too right team oddball is like capture
the flag as long as one of your
teammates holds that shiny macguffin
disco ball you'll rack up points quickly
it can also be used as a weapon which
one taps the enemy which is surprisingly
fun gun game is here too and it allows
you to get your hands on all weapons in
split gate and asks you a simple
question can you murder someone with
each of these weapons rocket launchers
shotguns pistols a riot bat and the last
elim is fists only play this game mode
to quickly get to grips with all the
weapons you'll have much more time to
use in other modes this game mode is all
about mayhem all 22 tiers of it team
shotty snipers is another great mode
which is essentially team deathmatch but
only with sniper rifles and shotguns
long range and short range only great
for practicing your strats and finding
cheeky portal camping points all while
checking you can still be aware of those
fools who try to bum rush you team swat
is a great mode that rewards head shots
it's a one bullet elimination regardless
of the weapon if you hit them in the
brain box you can take a bunch of shots
to the torso before going down but a
single bullet to the dome wins this
fight if you're looking to improve your
aim and first shot accuracy play this
mode teams what on top of that there are
a bunch of limited time modes which come
and go into the game every so often
right now i'm playing instagib and i
love this mode it's a free-for-all where
every bullet is a one shot kill
basically hitting someone in the toe is
just like a head shot
every one of us has an instacharge
railgun with limitless bullets you'll
die a bunch of times but those moments
where you rack up six kills in a row are
immense
one in the chamber is another great mode
again it's a one bullet kill but if you
miss that bullet you have no bullets
left you must use your fists instead if
you successfully shoot someone and take
their life you get another bullet in
your weapon rinse and repeat simple idea
but it works really well and finally a
game mode i cannot support
teabag confirm yes i'm sure you've
already figured out what that means to
confirm your kill you must debug the
player you just offed to some that'll be
great to others that is a hate crime in
itself and to make this worse split gate
tracks how many times you've teabagged a
player how much of a good boy are you
that's a handful of game modes to try
out right now in split gate and they've
promised lots more are coming in the
future and those who want to get sweaty
there is a competitive playlist for both
three and four squad games
so how the hell do the split gate team
make money if their game is free i bet
you've already guessed it cosmetic items
just like the trend is these days
splitgate uses a battle pass and a
storefront to get your cash and from
what i've seen there's an okay selection
to choose from in the store too it
definitely is early days though here as
it's the first person shooter the real
customization we all want is a weapon
wrap and that's when something good
happens not only can cosmetics be bought
in the store and via the battle pass
they can be earned in-game through
eliminations and other challenges golden
weapon wraps will be yours one day there
are tons to unlock all completely for
free they may not be as fancy as the
paid stuff but it's still possible to
look your way without breaking the bank
and there's also a steady stream of free
loot boxes to help entice you just
promise you won't get addicted oh and
you can even change the color of your
portals if you wanted to i like that
touch the future of split gate is in the
balance right now a seemingly great idea
almost died a couple of years ago when
it first released at the pc community
but a dev team of four people kept
working at it to evolve and update the
game into what we see today soon
splitgate will leave open beta and we'll
know exactly what direction it wants to
take us with a replay function coming
nextgen upgrades to ps5 and xbox series
x and a switch version is coming too
split gate certainly has potential but
it will need support to keep going i
have to admit i really like split gate
and it have about 40 tips to improve
your gameplay if anyone would be
interested in that i would really like
to add split gate to our regular covered
games here but of course that choice is
yours not mine watching this video helps
a like helps even more a comment too
shall we do this if you're still here
please write the cake is a lie in the
comments and for the first few hours
today i'll try and send a reply to
everyone who does thank you very much
for your time i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you in split gate i'll be the
guy chasing himself through portals
[Music]
you